- Again it's Earth day!
Don't be trashy.
(audience claps and cheers)
♪ It's Earth Day, don't be trashy ♪
♪ Don't be trashy ♪
- Don't be trashy. (laughs)
We loved watching our next guest
as a vampire in the Twilight movies.
She's also a mama, and
entrepreneur, and an eco-warrior.
Her sustainable jewelry collection,
"BaYou with Love" is out right now.
You got to check it out.
Please welcome, Nikki Reed! (claps)
(classic upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
Hi!
I love you too!
(classic upbeat music continues)
Oh my God!
I wish I can hug you.
- Hi.
- I'm such a fan.
This is so exciting
for so many reasons.
- Urgh!
First of all, I haven't seen a human
in a long time.
(Kelly laughs and claps)
So, I was like,
- Yeah.
"Thanks for giving me a reason to like,
shave my legs like,
- Yes.
- Maybe put deodorant on?
Although,
- Oh,
you did both those things?
- Not sure if I did that.
Your ahead of the game.
As far as I'm concerned.
- We're far apart.
- I'm just kidding! (laughs)
- Hi.
- Nice to see you.
And I love your outfit!
- Thank you!
- My Gosh!
Your so great right now!
- This is um,
No, I mean, this isn't meant to be a plug
but this is a sustainable suit by--
- Is it?
- A company called,
"Another Tomorrow."
And then, these are
shoes that are made from
post-consumer ocean plastics.
- Oh my gosh!
- Yeah.
- You're like a walking, like environment,
like eco-friendly person.
I love you.
Well, I want to talk about
this because actually,
Ian was on the show, he's late and,
your husband, and he was
telling me about your jewelry.
And so, your jewelry line
is made from recycled tech
which I'm not surprised about.
So, tell everyone about BaYou with Love.
- Thank you, for asking
- Yeah.
- About BaYou and so,
you know, I spend so much
time talking about other--
- Is this you?
- Female founded companies.
- What you wearing?
- Cause I want to, yes, it is.
- Yeah.
- First of all, you also gave
me an opportunity to wear
jewelry for the first time
in a long time.
(Kelly laughs)
So, thank you, for that.
(audience laughing)
I, I put it all on.
- Yeah.
I ah, so, I started BaYou, in 2017.
I was pregnant with my
daughter and I wanted to,
(tongue ticks)
create products that I couldn't
find in the marketplace.
- So, I was Googling like,
- Yeah.
organic underwear,
like chemical free underwear, you know?
The things that you only
Google when you're pregnant.
Right?
- Yes!
- So, we launched with
Multipurpose Apothecary.
I have this kinda mantra that like,
versatility is the key to sustainability.
So, it's not so much about
producing sustainable products
as it is producing less
products that serve more,
more than one purpose.
But we quickly moved from
that into fine jewelry
because I come from a long history lineage
of jewelry designers and--
- I love that!
- My grandmother was an artist.
My great, great grandmother
was a jewelry designer.
And I love the idea of
creating pieces that,
(inhales)
are heirloom pieces, you know?
They're meant to last a lifetime.
And that's what we're
not doing right now in,
- Yeah.
- In, in the fashion space.
But in every industry
across the board basically,
with like, you know, consumer
driven products and companies.
It's like more and more and more.
A seasonal trends, how can I--
- Quantity, not quality.
Yeah.
- Exactly!
And it needs to be about quality.
And it needs to be about
less and spending a lifetime.
And so, I love the idea of creating pieces
that can be passed down from
generation to generation.
And God forbid, they end
up in a landfill, you know?
Gold is gold, no matter
where it comes from.
So, whether you're sourcing
it from the inside a computer,
like we are, or, you know?
Whether it's come from, you know,
traditional mining operations?
It's still gold and if it
goes back into the earth,
I feel good about that.
We also use diamonds that are grown
with solar energy above ground--
- I found this interesting.
- In California.
- Wow! What?
- So, grown diamonds are
actually molecularly identical
to traditionally mined diamonds.
So, they're not fake.
They're not CZs.
They're not, but there's not
a lot of information on this.
So they're, they're,
the chemical properties
and molecular properties are identical.
But without the human and
environmental toll of mining.
So, we're creating, you know?
- Wow!
That's revolutionary.
- Sustainable,
- In the whole industry.
(Nikki laughs)
Yeah!
- Thanks!
Thank you!
- Yeah!
Yeah!
- So, okay, so you're,
well, your husband has
been here a couple of times
and I have to ask you this because--
- No! (laughs)
- The first time was awesome.
You have to see this.
I want you to watch before
we talk, here we go.
- Uh-Oh!
(majestic music starts)
(audience cheering and clapping)
(high fives)
- Oh! (laughs)
- Your a high fiver! I love it!
- [Ian] Yeah!
- I'm a hugger!
(majestic music continues)
(high fives)
- Oh my God!
Wait, a slow mo high fives?
(high fives)
(Nikki laughs)
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Oh my God!
(high fives)
What is happening?
You're not doing repeats?
That's like, all in one?
- Yes! There you go sister!
(high fives)
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Look at your face.
Look at your,
(Kelly laughing)
- Those are legit!
- Look at our face.
- Those are, those are not repeats.
Those are all the high fives.
- All I can say is that,
"What a weirdo?"
- No!(laughs and claps)
He was sitting close enough to hug you.
And I'm so far from you
and I wanna launch myself--
- Oh my God!
- On you and hug you.
- No, he was so nice!
- You know what?
Actually, the other thing I'm thinking is
maybe he was onto something
and he was like having
a psychic premonition
because the high fiving is very 2020.
And that looks like,
it was very 2019.
(Kelly laughs and claps)
- And so,
- He was like,
You know, he's like,
"Let's elbow now,
and high five.
- He--
- And sanitize."
- I was like,
my question is, does he high fives a lot?
(audience laughing)
- Um ah...
(sighs)
(Kelly laughs)
- It's you?
- I feel that's him
very excited!
I don't know.
(Kelly laughs and claps)
Maybe he was so nervous
around you that's why...
Maybe, he's not excited
- He was like? (laughs)
- In our house?
- Oh my God!
So, I don't know, I--
- It was awesome!
- That was special!
That was for you!
- I was like,
He likes more on like,
"He likes to high five!"
Almost like, I like it!
- I don't know.
Yeah!
- I just, to see him, what?
Maybe, you know what? I'm gonna tell you.
It made me feel really good.
I was like, "Amped?
Ready to play a game of some sort?"
- Totally!
- Yeah, yeah.
- He was amping you up.
- I know.
- That's he was saying,
he was pumping you up.
He is.
- He's so fun.
Every time he comes.
He just came in and we had
his alcohol in here too.
And it was so good!
- Yeah, it's good!
And yeah, but I love you too.
You both look like you're from,
coming from like, some really cool fair,
like festival?
(Nikki laughs)
Always, you look like,
so put together and like, I'm like,
"Oh, that's what people look
like sometimes, I guess?
Not me! (laughs)
- We're doing the Earth Day episode.
So, I guess it was tempting to like,
come out with like, hemp seeds in my hair.
- I think it looks so cool though.
Specially, the companies
- Put jewelry and,
that you're wearing right now too.
I think that's so important
- Thanks!
- Cause you look bad-ass and like,
- That's what a great outfit.
- You know,
- And also,
looking out for the planet.
- My new jam is trying to figure out,
how we can wear the same things
over and over again and
make them look different?
- Well, Simon Cowell's been
doing that for quite some time.
He just, (laughs)
(Nikki laughs)
he has been wearing the same
black shirt and jeans for,
since I've known him.
- He's a trend setter.
- He--
He was trend setter.
- He's a real trend setter.
(Nikki laughs)
- He cares about the earth
more than all of us.
(claps)
So, well, for more
information about Nikki's
sustainable jewelry line
and lifestyle company,
"BaYou with Love."
Y'all gotta check out on Instagram.
It's awesome.
She's wearing it all right now.
And I'm loving it!
- I brought you a present too.
- Oh, you did?
- Yes, I did!
They hid it.
- Oh?
Oh shoot, I don't think
I'd be allowed to touch it.
- No, you can't, but I'll just show you.
- Oh, COVID!
- So, I know.
I was gonna meet, I was like,
"Can I throw it at her?"
Now, that's weird.
(audience laughing)
That's more weird than high-fiving.
- Just grow over it, just, (laughs)
- So, this ring is for you.
- Oh my Gosh!
That's beautiful!
- I noticed you weren't
wearing any ring.
- I know,
I literally got here today
and I looked at myself and I was like,
"I forgot all my jewelry at home."
Cause I put it up where it goes.
- Yeah, well just,
- That's why I forgot it.
- When you've just worn
and you'll never take it off.
So, this is called,
- Thank you!
- The "Good Eye" ring
because I just don't
believe in the word evil
being incorporated into anything that--
With the evil, that's so
funny that you said that--
- Yeah.
- Cause that scares me.
Every time I wear a jewelry, I'm like,
"What does this mean?" (laughs)
- Now you have, this is the Good Eye.
- I like the good eye.
- So it stays with you.
- I love that!
- And also,
carries a message of
love and sustainability.
- You are like, such goals
for just being a human,
not just a woman.
(audience cheers and claps)